Jordan a fresh graduate is working as a
sophomore engineer at a big firm saving
money for higher studies one day he came
to know that the bank where he was
saving money got bankrupt and all his
money was now gone with the bank
Jordan was confused how come if the bank
had gone bankrupt his money was also
gone
when his friend Jack learned about this
he explained that banks are basically a
centralized system for storing the data
of all transactions Banks rotate money
to ensure the existence of the money of
their customers for instance the amount
of money appearing on your account is
just a number of value so if they go
through any crisis your money also comes
at risk
a real life example of this was the
bankruptcy of layman brothers when they
caused a global recession
in a nutshell by giving your money to
the bank you are giving control of your
money to someone else and this causes
the problem of transparency
and this doesn't stop there
due to the irrational ratio of Banks and
data present technical failures and
double spending we're due to internal
server issues the amount gets deducted
twice became prominent issues
Jordan was shocked to know such an
in-depth mechanism of Banks and how they
negatively affect their money and
wondered if these issues are so
prominent what is a solution
and that's when Jack replied well there
is a solution and it's Bitcoin Jordan
was confused and asked what Bitcoin is
Jack explained that Bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency that came into existence
in 2008 a white paper was published by a
guy named Satoshi Nakamoto suggesting a
way of creating a system for a
decentralized currency called Bitcoin
its motive was to show the world that
the decentralized control structure can
work with the institutional government
Bitcoin claimed to create a digital
solution that would solve all these
problems like double spending corruption
and low transparency without the need
for a central Authority
Jordan was excited to know about Bitcoin
but needed clarification about how
Bitcoin can solve such issues that large
institutions like Banks cannot
Jack further explained that Bitcoin is a
transparent Ledger without a central
Authority and works on blockchain
technology
blockchain is a system for storing data
in a way that makes it challenging or
impossible to alter hack or defraud the
system a blockchain is simply a network
of computer systems that maintains
duplicate copies of all transactions in
a digital Ledger disseminated throughout
the network
and BTC is the currency used to make
those transactions successful and as
there are no middlemen the transaction
cost is way cheaper as each system in
the network carries a copy of The Ledger
or transaction stored in it making it
impossible to hack or manipulate because
to do so you will have to take down or
hack every system or node participating
in the network
Bitcoin is completely digital
Jordan after knowing this ask how it
could solve his problem and how he could
get access to bitcoin if it's completely
digital
Jack explained that one can always buy
Bitcoins once you own Bitcoin it gives
you a specific ID which gives you full
control over your money using that IDE
you can send or receive funds in your
Bitcoin account that can be later
converted into any currency anytime you
want
so if he would have invested that same
amount in Bitcoin years ago he could
have easily accessed it and it would
have been worth much more than they were
years ago
another reference is a Vignesh
sundarison famously known as medicovan
who became a billionaire with just five
thousand dollars investment all because
of Bitcoin
so these examples are powerful enough to
establish the fact that Bitcoin is the
best alternative for today's Financial
establishment and also how bright its
future is going to be
well here's a question for you where are
all the Bitcoin transactions stored
a blockchain b digital Ledger C private
key
D crypto wallet
think about it and leave your answers in
the comments section and we will provide
the answer next week give the correct
answer along with your reasoning and
stand a chance to win an Amazon voucher
Jordan was slightly relieved but still
curious to know that if Bitcoin is a
solution to all the problems then why is
it not used or implemented by everyone
Jack mentioned that Bitcoin is an
alternative to the current system and it
cannot be controlled by any bank or
government
although there are some great benefits
of Bitcoin many people like Warren
Buffett and Mark Cuban still view it as
risky big economies including the U.S
China Japan and others have actually
endorsed this currency however this
currency is still clouded in question as
a result of the territorial struggle
many top companies like Microsoft
Expedia KFC and Overstock believe in
Bitcoin and use it as a currency mode
and maybe in the coming years it will
gain more people's trust and ultimately
revolutionize the whole economic system
of the world
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on the Bell icon for
more on the latest Technologies and
Trends thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from Simply learn
[Music]